those are things we don't want in the
United States and one other thing
there's people with predatory behavior
in every excuse me but you get mad at me
but if I could say this it's not baked
into their religion Trump supporters can
I have you over there
my immigrants can I have you in the
other light sometimes I feel anxious
about how the other side views me so
it's not necessarily about the idea of
immigrants but I'm Muslim and there can
be a lot of directed aggression from
trans supporters that I think I felt and
other people in my Muslim community have
felt and that's why I'm here sitting
with you guys I own a clothing line
Magga preneur this is my clothing line
I'm a political strategist and a
political activist and when I leave my
house I am in fear for my life because
every day I get death threats so I think
we both should be able to freely express
ourselves I love everybody I'm here for
everybody I'll fight for your right for
freedom but I expect for you to fight
for mine too
because that's why we're in America my
name is chefs Tina so I absolutely love
immigration but I believe that we need
to secure our border and it's the same
thing of I wouldn't just let anyone in
my car or in my house all right
disagrees come on in
I used to get anxious about how I'm
perceived not just by some quote-unquote
other side because my identity is very
apparent in standing in my truth I think
it allows other folks to stand in theirs
and to invite people to also learn more
about me rather than be worried about
how I'm perceived I think my group gets
represented unfairly in the media well
I'm a Mexican and I hesitated because
when Trump said that things about
Mexicans been criminals and all that I I
didn't took it personal because I'm not
that so I was like that does not
represent me like I'll take things yeah
so that's why I hesitated but then I'm
like I am NOT only one Mexican
individual who's an immigrant I'm part
of all the immigrants no matter what
country you're from we can say the same
thing for Trump supporters right I mean
now we have to maybe I wasn't called a
racist but you were called racist well
guess what
we're both Trump supporters so now we
have to band together could I could I
ask both of you a question and I'd like
an honest reaction to this in my mind
it's languaging I'm a writer and I think
if we made a distinction between
jihadists and Muslims that would solve a
big problem that's plausible and I think
a lot of that goes in it's really the
realm of how much people really are
interested in understanding that kind of
diversification and allowing the
community that does know that really I
don't know take the lead and initiative
and show other people what that's about
I feel threatened by this presidency
when President Trump got elected as
president I was scared even though I had
not a reason to because I'm legal here
power becomes scary in hands of a
monster power becomes scary Nance of
ignorance and I'm scared about my people
and not only like I said the Mexicans
all they're good hard-working immigrants
yeah I think the election night was when
I felt alarmed I've been a community
organizer and an activist for 15 years
now right that night it felt like a slap
in the face to all of the work that we
have always tried to do in terms of
humanizing ourselves my name is Kip I
shot I think we realize as immigrants
how lucky we are to be here and that's
why we want to create a society that's
more welcoming for others to be here you
said it was a slap in the face and I
take offense to that because you're
saying you work so hard and yet we work
so hard to to elect a president of the
United States that we think will enforce
the the laws we'll enforce the United
States Constitution and it wasn't to be
racist or it wasn't to boot you out of
the country and it was to enforce the
First Amendment it's actually to enforce
your freedom of speech I understand why
you're scared that as a white Trump
supporter I am scared of this presidency
because I have lost my freedom of speech
I have lost my freedom of religion I
have lost my freedom to wear this shirt
in the public just because I have a
different political view now I'm the
enemy in my own country I think that
that's unfortunate about happened to you
but it's almost like you have some
semblance of the reality that people of
color live with for centuries here and
I've never seen that and I've never the
first time you felt that right right but
I I'm just gonna let you know that my
neighbors are black I have Muslim
neighbors I have I have neighbors of all
kinds when we go to the grocery store
and I'm picking out yogurt I'm picking
out yogurt this looks like someone just
like you but it doesn't mean that you
experience the same thing I think even
though we eat the same yogurt
but nobody in my County treats people
like that it's just not I don't think
you would be able to say that I've lived
in Orange County up until a few months
ago if I'm at a mall or if I'm even at
the beach right I get a lot of strange
stares I even feel like a lot of people
after the election came up to me asking
me about my positions my religion my
identity so what I'm trying to say is
like I can actually relate to what you
went through because that to be honest
is a shred of similarity to what people
of color we came here and then we were
born basically sure I believe in
immigration but I am against illegal
immigration my whole thing is
assimilation right so like making sure
that the culture is match if you know
someone in the Middle East who's gay
will be killed right that's a thing and
it's horrible if someone would that
culture is somehow makes it through
vetting and comes here and then sees a
gay couple you know kissing or whatever
they're gonna freak out or they're gonna
react very differently in a way that you
know we're trying to move past or not
trying to be held back by so I believe
assimilation is probably one of the most
important factors of why we need legal
and not illegal immigrations my thing is
about money an awful lot of people who
came here legally don't want illegal
people being able to come or get free
college it costs a hundred and eighteen
billion dollars in welfare benefits
that's a huge why do I have to pay so
that Walmart has cheap workers my name
is Ken hunger I don't have anything
against immigrants it's a political
problem it's not an immigrant problem I
was an illegal immigrant at one point in
my life I am not anymore but ultimately
we left a country of war a country where
extremism and terrorism was a reality
and this is something that was on a
daily oppression towards women if we
don't have legal immigration and we'll
have that here we want you to come and
be safe but don't you want that for
everyone else
doesn't matter where you're coming from
I think it might be a misconstrued
and/or a misconception to think that the
illegal immigrants might bring up the
crime rates and when we're talking about
what happens after immigrants or
refugees or illegals or anything coming
to the state and how can we help them
from here I think that is the real
essential question we have a
humanitarian duty to help one another
out regardless of if we're Afghan if
we're Israeli if we're American we're
all humans ultimately it's so fantastic
but what about our vets what about our
children that are starving what about
our foster homes that are full what
about them we're not helping them we're
taking in all these refugees if we can't
fix our citizens how can we fix others
it's just kind of like if I can't love
myself I can't love another person it
should be easier to immigrate into
America
it should be easier the way time should
be shorter right but I believe that it's
so lengthy not because the process is so
extreme I've I mean personally I think
it's so lengthy because it's mismanaged
yeah I think that well that too but I
think it's just like there's a way in a
process that should be put in place so
it's not 15 years let's say that they
fully cooperate right let's say they
have everything they have all the
documents and they're ready
yeah I think it should be a lot shorter
do you think make it less bureaucratic
yeah basically okay I mean I think I
would agree with that I just feel like
when it comes to Trump you support the
individual but then the bureaucracy the
administration all of that is so
painstaking just so inefficient and in
all of this it doesn't really compute
for me so I think we've been in there a
year right yeah we have so many changes
that we want to make so let's talk about
a couple of policy things what about the
Muslim banner the travel ban the travel
ban to me was more about Obama but it
was enacted by Trump don't don't get me
wrong I agree with the travel ban right
and I agree with refugees but that's two
separate things to me so what I'm trying
to say is that none of these policies
that are happening are not to do with
one another they're all intertwined when
we say we support the travel ban but we
also support refugees but we also want
to like help them get vaccinations and
we also want to do that some islands
want to well don't forget we're funding
the same bombs that are causing the
Yemenis to have to become route there
has to be a reason right so so it's so
it's all it's all it's all connected
right so so why are we bombing Yemen
personally I haven't looked into Yemen I
guess I'm missing your point refugees
you support yes
travel ban this one ban you support it's
not me it's not a mother yes I support a
travel ban so we can assess who's coming
in I just think it's important to
contextualize like you're saying nothing
happens in a vacuum
yeah right and I think that if we start
to actually connect the dots like I'm
encouraging us to do then it'll become a
lot more understandable I mean I don't
believe
anyway I would like to answer your
question about why we're bombing Yemen
we're not palm in Yemen were bombing
radical jihadists in Yemen who were
killing people that's why we're bombing
parts of Yemen selectively to kill
people who are doing terrible terrible
things and there's a tremendous amount
of rape happening in England taking
these little girls grooming them because
they feel they have the right to do we
don't want that here those are things we
don't want in the United States and one
other thing there's people with
predatory behavior in every excuse me if
I could say this and you'll get mad at
me but if I could say this it's not
baked into their religion there are a
hundred and nine passages in the Quran
where people are told to kill infidels
and in Christians and Jews there's
nothing like that in our Bible or in the
bhagavad-gita or in anything Buddha
taught or any other religion I'm aware
of in the world until people renounce
those values then they scare me I don't
think so I haven't renounced any part of
my religion in front of you so I hope
that you don't feel threatened by me so
I'm not sure what you mean by that
and I won't renounce any part of it slam
the point that I'm trying to make is
that you didn't really answer the
question no he did he said the reason
why we're bombing him on Yemen is to
save the people because I'm assuming
that in Yemen we've managed to keep out
people like that guys remember this is a
video of a trumpet immigrants we're
mixing too much the religion well I
think the race the Taliban yes yes that
you shouldn't question somebody's
religion I am very religious very
religious and I'm not putting anything
about my religion in here I'm here to
talk about me as an immigrant you guys
are here to talk about Donald Trump's
like supporting him and yes I've learned
a lot like you guys are human too you
have values you who would have thought
you know that we would have found
common ground and we wouldn't like hit
each other right here you know because
after the media portraying you guys as
bad or closest terrorist whatever right
I think the media is getting us all in a
different light yeah I think that we're
portraying ourselves in a very different
light too I mean I feel very attacked
just now for my religion when I did
start to talk about myself as an
immigrant you don't say you kept talking
about the travel ban it's a Muslim but
that has nothing to do with immigration
it's not a Muslim but what I'm trying to
just say is that no one should have to
explain Muslim Christian Jewish none of
the above what they are to you but
Muslims continuously have to defend not
only their religion but their humanity
what I love about this country is the
diversity I just when I came here from
Mexico I just loved how there was
different religions different colors
different people like it's amazing it's
it's beautiful and I don't I don't
understand how empty of a human you have
to be to discriminate someone just
because of their looks it's it's these
pre-programmed thoughts in our head from
just media as what I believe just
blowing things out of proportion just
consistently just the outlook on
minorities or the outlook on people in
certain situations is just bad once you
humanize someone when you're having a
conversation when I and I look past you
know whatever these biases that people
try to enact on me right or that I see
and I start looking at you as a person I
start listening to what you're saying
you really realize that it's not that
different I mean we just we have
different situations we have different
information but we're all trying to do
the best that we have I think the real
interesting aspect that I guess a lot of
discrimination is really about is taking
this general idea of phenomenon where
you can associate my case at least like
Muslims terrorists equal each other and
take individuals and group them so
easily with that sort of discrimination
and I think that's something that we
have to work towards in terms of
separating ourselves from doing that
thank you everybody I appreciate you
[Music]
all right hey guys thanks for watching
that episode of middle ground my name is
Taylor my name is Dan please leave us a
comment and let us know your thoughts on
this topic we'd love to hear some
discussion going on in the comments keep
it friendly
keep it cool we love for you guys to get
involved in any way possible so please
subscribe watch more videos leave
comments we live for that and see you
later